[Música]
para silva hoy a segunda vuelta en las
elecciones municipales está en juego el
liderazgo en 57 municipios incluyendo
seis de las mayores ciudades del país la
atención está sobre sao paulo y río de
janeiro las dos más pobladas y más
importantes que juegan como medidor
nacional
protestas en argentina miles de
ciudadanos se plantaron frente al
congreso en buenos aires en rechazo al
proyecto de ley que busca legalizar el
aborto el pliego enviado al parlamento
por el presidente alberto fernández es
un nuevo intento por ampliar las
causales legales de interrupción del
embarazo
y en etiopía del gobierno anunció que la
operación en tigre está completa el
presidente había ahmed a aseguró que sus
tropas tomaron control de la capital
regional mekelle tras tres semanas de
guerra étnica con rebeldes en el cuerno
de áfrica
una feliz mañana de domingo mi nombre es
ángela gómez y aquí comienzan las
noticias de france 24 iniciamos en
américa latina' hoy es día de elecciones
en brasil 38 3 millones de personas
están convocadas a las urnas para elegir
en segunda vuelta a los alcaldes de 57
grandes ciudades del país incluyendo
metrópolis como sao paulo o río de
janeiro y fortaleza el balotaje sucede
en las ciudades con más de 200.000
electores en las que ningún candidato
obtuvo mayoría absoluta en primera ronda
el pasado 15 de noviembre por lo que
será necesario realizar la votación en
60 % de 95 territorios hoy votarán en
seis de los diez mayores colegios
electorales de brasil sao paulo río de
janeiro fortaleza manaos recife y porto
allegre en la víspera de los comicios
habló el presidente del tribunal supremo
electoral luis roberto barroso y pidió
salir a votar este domingo se decidirá
este domingo se decidirá quién va a
gobernar algunas de las mayores ciudades
del país incluidas 18 capitales 38
millones de electores
irán a las urnas incluso si no se
presentó a las urnas en primera vuelta
puede hacerlo ahora una vez más vengo a
pedir a los electores que no dejen de
votar ayude a escribir este último
capítulo de las elecciones de 2020 este
según lee último capítulo de las
elecciones de 2005 en otras noticias
cientos de argentinos protestaron en
buenos aires para rechazar el proyecto
de ley presentado por el gobierno que
busca la legalización del aborto los
ciudadanos marcharon con pañuelos azules
símbolo de quienes rechazan esta
práctica y aseguraron que se haga de
manera legal o ilegal la terminación de
la vida es un crimen informe de
valentina torre sánchez
[Música]
argentina dice sí a la vida
con esta y otras consignas cientos de
argentinos protestaron frente a la sede
del congreso en buenos aires contra el
proyecto de ley impulsado por el
gobierno de alberto fernández que busca
un aborto legal seguro y gratuito lo
cual hoy estamos aquí presentes de
manera emblemática porque es sábado y no
están los diputados en el congreso pero
de manera telemática para que nuestros
diputados entiendan cuál es la voluntad
del pueblo y al mismo tiempo también
ejerzan su rol de representantes su rol
es representar a la gente no pueden
hacer caso a sus convicciones sino a la
voluntad del pueblo con banderas del
país pancartas cruces y pañuelos azules
que se han convertido en el símbolo de
quienes rechazan la interrupción del
embarazo los ciudadanos cantaron y
corearon arengas de forma pacífica en mi
experiencia personal
18 años y obviamente que en un principio
pensé
también pensé en dar una versión voy mi
hijo tiene 30 años
es el mayor orgullo
actualmente en el país el aborto solo
está permitido cuando hay violación o
riesgo para la vida de la madre
el proyecto de ley contempla que
cualquier mujer podría acceder a esta
práctica hasta la semana 14 y más allá
de ese plazo si se presentan las dos
causales actualmente vigentes la
normativa que en 2018 fue rechazada por
el senado empezará a ser discutida
nuevamente en la cámara a partir de
diciembre
pasamos a guatemala donde continúa el
descontento social contra la corrupción
en el país este sábado se volvieron a
registrar multitudinarias protestas en
frente al palacio nacional en ciudad de
guatemala la capital de la nación
centroamericana
cientos de personas exigen la renuncia
del presidente alejandro giammatei luego
de que su gobierno impulsará un
controversial proyecto de presupuesto
para el 2021 lo que desató una ola de
manifestaciones sociales en contra de su
administración
creemos importante que en la ciudadanía
se pueda pronunciar que pueda salir a
las calles que pueda exigir la renuncia
de toda esta de toda esta gente porque
sólo de esa forma podemos crear cambios
importantes verdad y la gente está
molesta indignada del gobierno que no
hace absolutamente nada por nadie
entonces la gente está harta y esta es
la muestra porque la gente está cansada
cambiamos de continente de etiopía
declaró de la victoria sobre los
rebeldes en la región separatistas de
tigre el ejército nacional etíope
aseguró que había tomado la ciudad de m
que le capital de esta región la
autoridad afirmó que se logró sin causar
daños colaterales a su población el
gobierno llevaba semanas luchando contra
el frente de liberación popular de tigre
veamos el informe
misión cumplida o eso aseguran estas
imágenes publicadas por el ejército
etíope afirman que sus tropas ya han
entrado a mekelle el ejército confirmó
que ya capturó la ciudad capital de la
región separatista de tigre sin víctimas
civiles
de nuestro ejército después de haberse
preparado ayer sobre cómo controlar la
ciudad de méxico les incautara daños
colaterales ha tomado el control total
de merkel e desde esta tarde las pesadas
vuelan a mcallen mumbrú
el gobierno dice que liberó a unos 7.000
soldados federales que habían sido
hechos prisioneros y ahora está
procediendo a perseguir a los líderes
rebeldes del frente de liberación
popular de tigre el primer ministro
etíope había met escribió un tuit en el
que aseguró que las operaciones habían
llegado a su fin en la región mientras
tanto el frente de liberación popular de
tigre asegura que me que le ha sido
objeto de bombardeos durante los últimos
días el fin de semana pasado el gobierno
emitió una advertencia de que me que le
sería bombardeado indiscriminadamente a
menos que los rebeldes dejasen las armas
por su parte el líder de tigre aseguró
que sus fuerzas tienen la intención de
seguir luchando y afirmó que se trata de
defender su derecho a la
autodeterminación el frente de
liberación dominó en el pasado una
coalición gobernante en etiopía antes de
ser marginado por amplias reformas
políticas lideradas por arabia med desde
su ascenso al poder en 2018 las
afirmaciones del gobierno nacional y del
ejército de liberación son casi
imposibles de verificar ya que la región
permanece prácticamente aislada se cree
que miles de personas murieron en los
combates desde que comenzó la campaña
militar del gobierno para
el control de tigre hace tres semanas en
irán se realizó la sepultura del
científico josefa crista de fallecido en
un ataque el investigador ha señalado
por eeuu e israel de continuar con la
actividad nuclear en el país el ayatolá
alí jamenéi señaló al gobierno de
benjamín netanyahu y prometió
represalias
y funerales de estado debido a la
situación sanitaria
la procesión funeraria de hemos
enfatizado ha sido difundida por el
canal estatal iraní así como la visita
del ministro de defensa su viuda el
científico murió el viernes cerca de
teherán en un ataque no reivindicado su
muerte ha desatado la ira de numerosos
iraníes y muchos han salido a
manifestarse a pesar de las medidas
sanitarias nuestra sangre está en
ebullición y no descansaremos hasta que
no hayamos obtenido la revancha por la
muerte de mohsén táctica de una llamada
a la venganza difundida por twitter por
el ayatolá jamenéi que ha llamado a
represalias para el gobierno iraní el
asesinato lleva la firma de israel hemos
enfatizado fue el jefe del programa
nuclear iraní entre 1989 y 2003 y estaba
acusado por eeuu israel de seguir con su
actividad pese al acuerdo nuclear el
gobierno israelí no ha hecho
declaraciones sobre el ataque pero ha
puesto a sus embajadas en estado de
alerta
al menos 34 personas su mayoría
militares habrían perdido la vida en dos
ataques suicidas en afganistán informes
preliminares indican que los ataques con
carrobomba fueron perpetrados contra una
base militar y un convoy oficial en el
primero registrado en la provincia de
ghazni 31 soldados murieron y más de 24
resultaron heridos mientras que en el
segundo fallecieron tres personas
y en información sobre la pandemia la
organización mundial de la salud o
confirmó que europa superó las 400.000
muertes el 'viejo continente' es la
segunda región más golpeada luego de
américa a la fecha hay más de 18
millones de casos en todo el territorio
europeo
y el actor david prowse e interpretó a
darth vader en la trilogía original de
star wars falleció a los 85 años propuso
un el levantador de pesas convertido en
actor era mejor conocido por su papel
del padre de luke skywalker por usar el
icónico traje negro en la trilogía
original de 1977 a 1983 el acento
británico no se consideró adecuado para
el papel y sus líneas fueron expresadas
por james earl jones
hasta aquí el informativo y regresamos
en minutos con más síganos en france 24
y en france 24 punto com buenos días
[Música]
r efe